Chancellor thank you for talking to us
here at Davos and what do you make of
the Queen's comments overnight well I
think what the Queen said is what most
of us feel that we have to come together
we have to find common ground and most
of all we have to compromise to ensure a
smooth exit from the European Union and
and a way of doing that which protects
Britain's future prosperity there are
still at the moment too many people
advocating their preferred solutions
rather than looking for compromises to
an acceptable outcome for all of us so
compromise can you can you expand on
that well look it's very clear that
there are some people who would like us
to leave the European Union and and have
a very arm's length relationship with
the European Union there are others who
would like us to remain in the European
Union the right way forward and what the
government's seeking is for us to leave
with a deal that allows us to continue a
closed trading relationship a close
security partnership with our nearest
neighbors in a way that respects the
political decision of the British people
to be outside the European Union but
also allows us to prosper in the future
protects our jobs our businesses our
supply chains and our prosperity if
there were a No Deal and that chances
are clearly rising we're heading towards
that article 50 deadline would you feel
in good faith you could carry on as
Chancellor preside over that well my job
is to ensure that we don't get to that
point that we don't there is a daily
threat we're heading towards that day
there there is a risk of course there's
a risk of no deal and if God forbid that
is the outcome then there's an absolute
obligation to manage that situation so
you would still minimize the minimize
the impact would pledge to say I think
my job is to try to maximize the future
prosperity of the UK to allow us to
seize the opportunity nevermind brexit
there are huge opportunities around
technology transformation around our
services sector it's about maximizing
the opportunities for Britain and the
British people ahead and if we did find
that we were facing a no deal exit then
we would we would do everything we could
to mitigate and minimize the damage that
that would inflict on the British
economy but nobody should be in any
doubt that it would be a very bad
outcome but specially economy you would
stick on in that case I'm telling you
what I think my obligations are right
okay and and when it comes to brexit
events and many other issues that people
are talking about here in Davos does it
frustrate you that a lot of attention
for you for the civil service but
everyone in the UK is devoted to brexit
is it getting in the way of running the
economy oh of course it's a big
distraction but it's the single most
important issue that the UK faces at the
moment and it overshadows our economy
and dominates all other decisions that
we make is the way or a bad way well in
a bad way the uncertainty around our how
we're going to leave the European Union
and what our future trajectory looks
like is deeply unsettling for business
and we've heard that message here loud
and clear many investment decisions have
been postponed many investment funds are
deliberately avoiding investments in UK
stocks and and UK assets at the moment
and what we need to do of course is
deliver a good outcome to this process a
negotiated deal and we will see that
money flooding back into the UK and
giving us a prosperity boost
later on this year it's all talking on
that topic I mean we heard from Airbus
obviously yesterday and there have been
concerns about companies like Dyson for
instance moving their headquarters
overseas do you expect to see more of
this well the danger is that as we get
closer to the deadline with this issue
unresolved more and more businesses that
have made contingency plans to deal with
the possibility of an Odile exit feel
obliged to activate those plans and in
some cases they will make decisions
which are irreversible and that is bad
for the British economy so there is a
ticking clock here that the sooner we
resolve this with a good outcome that
reassures business that there will be a
sensible way forward a smooth
exit process and a trading partnership
with the European Union in the future
the fewer businesses and jobs we will
lose so so the pressures on we were told
by Airbus that the government had urged
them to make that announcement yesterday
isn't just you know project fair all
over again no well I don't I don't
recognize that line at all and what what
we have done is throughout this process
is said to businesses that if they have
concerns if they have information then
of course they should share it with us
and share it with the public it's very
important that people understand the
facts and make their decisions
accordingly these are very very
important decisions for the future of
our country and they need to be fully
informed